Як Ви вважаєте, розпад Радянського Союзу
негативно відобразИвся на Грузії?
Це стало катастрофою для Грузії як країни?
Так, катастрофою. Чому? Тому що…
От у нас удома ми часто про це говоримо.
Таке враження, що нас Бог карає.
Чомусь ми потрапили в розбірку.
Ну, як може собі нормальна людина уявити, що,
як говорять політики, Грузія оголосила війну Росії?
Це смішно. Як може ця манюсінька країна?
Та в одному лишень Дзержинському районі Москви,
мабуть, більше народу живе, ніж у всій Грузії.
Прибалти красиво пішли.
Ну, там були якісь неприємності, я все це пам'ятаю,
але вони все ж вилізли з цього.
І всю образу цю за розвал, яка лягла на Росію, він вирішив на нас...
З нас почав.
Ще більші неприємності у нас попереду. Таке в мене відчуття.
тому що я недавно дивився передачу московську. Політична така передача.
Там чоловік і жінка завжди ведучі.
Там один політолог якийсь прямо кричав:
"досить! Якщо якась наша колишня республіка
вирішить увійти в НАТО, ми вже прямо повинні вдарити їх.
Буквально слово в слово сказав. І ми попадаємо.
Чому? Ніби нас хтось прокляв.
І чим це завершиться, невідомо.
Якщо нас вчасно не приймуть до цього НАТО,
ця країна може зникнути.
Вахтанже Костянтиновичу, от ви заговорили про війну.
Цьогоріч виповнюється десять років п'ятиденній війні з Росією.
Чи можна було уникнути збройного конфлікту?
Не можна було, тому що в основній масі не знають, що відбувалося.
За багато років, багато років до цього вже цей регіон
- звідкись же це почалося з карти - сіпали, бомбили, стріляли.
Там гидота відбувалася, розумієте?
І коли в розбірку потрапив Міша Саакашвілі,
тому що він вочевидь повірив, що якщо ми почнемо оборонятися,
нас підтримають.
Приїхали якісь сміливі президенти семи країни
чи п'яти, я вже не пам'ятаю.
Польський, який загинув з цим літаком…
Так, Качинський.
Приїхав український президент.
Коли у людини горе, вона хоче когось знайти, хто зможе її підтримати…
Якщо ти зїздиш за 35 кілометрів звідси у напрямку Горі,
ти побачиш, що стоять оці дроти.
А за цими дротами російські військові ходять.
Ну, солдати ні до чого. Їм наказують - вони виконують.
І щомісяця цей дріт пересувається - це йде така повзуча анексія.
Ось чоловік тут живе. А за дротом у нього похована дружина.
Він не може піти на могилу. Там церква.
Там церква. Він не може помолитися.
Весь час дві-три людини зникають.
Вони нібито порушили кордон. Який кордон?
Це споконвіку наша грузинська земля.
Скажіть, а ви думаєте Грузія як держава може
повернути контроль над територією Абхазії та Південної Осетії?
Це реалістично?
Я свого часу в одному інтерв'ю написав:
"Якщо Володимир Путін вирішить це питання),
(іноді забувають, що і Росія, і Грузія - це православні народи
то його портрет висітиме в кожному домі", я кажу.
Тобто ключ до вирішення проблеми в руках у Путіна.
У Путіна, звичайно.
Ви десять років не їздили в Росію.
І це пов'язано з війною 2008 року.
За якої умови Ви поїдете в Росію?
Я написав в одному інтерв'ю, що я буду,
якщо ці "баскетболісти" підуть з політики.
Кого ви маєте на увазі конкретно?
Конкретно Путіна й Медведєва.
Тобто я правильно розумію, що Ви готові приїхати в Росію,
якщо і Путін, і Медведєв залишать свої посади?
Я готовий приїхати в Росію, бо я Росію дуже люблю.
В Росії уміють слухати пісні, дивитися кіно.
Я не думаю, що такий ажіотаж буде довкола мене через це.
Коли я сказав, що не хочу цей орден отримувати, я відмовився.
Тодішній посол, дуже симпатична була людина,
посол Росії, він мені сказав: "Буба, ви мене підставили".
Його перевели потім звідси.
Я завжди кажу, що я не можу співати людині, яка мене б'є.
А я не можу відповісти. Я пішов, усе.
Потім дуже багато моїх знайомих казали: а що тобі?
Ти ж бачиш, усі їздять, усі співають.
А я не можу. Може я не правий.
Але я для себе вважаю, що я правий.
Мені буде незручно дивитися дітям і онукам в очі.